hello everyone and welcome to the very
first episode of game review my name is
Caleb Denby and today I'm gonna be going
over a game from the from last year's
2019 world rapid championship I was a
very interesting event and one of the
breakout players was ali reza fruga he
is a 16 year old from iran and he
finished with 10 and a half points
actually tied for second place behind
the one and only magnus carlsen and
today i wanted to go over one of his
games against it ernesto in our kiev an
archive is also a very strong player
peaked well over 2,700 and gained some
some fame over the past year by claiming
an illegal move against magnus carlsen
and i think last year's blitz
championship no such controversies this
year for an archive but he did play this
game against fruga and i wanted to talk
about this game because it's very
typical of ali reza style he of course a
16 year old has grown up playing chess
on the internet and playing chess on the
internet gives you a lot of practical
abilities it makes you play the type of
chess where you give your opponent
chances to go wrong and you don't try to
you know force everything you just make
their position slightly awkward and let
them kind of blunder at their own pace
so let's see how you pulled it off in in
this game against anarchy of the game
started a 45 and we very quickly got
into the close droid Lopez with Knight
of 6 castles Bishop e7
rook e1 b5 and after a few more moves we
achieved this position after c3 and in
this case black actually chose the main
line Knight a5 hitting this bishop
forcing it off of this very natural long
diagonal on to this diagonal behind
behind his pawns and now black continues
with the very natural move c5 so he gets
this Knight out of the way and pushes
this pawn forward and the character of
this position is usually that you know
White's pieces are well placed to
support some central pushes and so
generally what happens
is after a few more moves we see Knight
bTW - rook e8 Knight f1 knight c6 and
generally the the tried-and-true method
here is to play some moves like Knight
g3 and after something like h3 and h6
why it's gonna go ahead and break in the
center with d4 and at first this
actually looks like a very very tempting
option for white it seems to create some
some real problems in the black position
generally in black captures and after
some exchanges on this square we see
that in this position it seems as though
black is left with a very weak D pawn
but the downside to having so many
exchanges so early on is that if black
manages to solve this problem of the D
pawn he is going to be completely equal
White's Center has been pretty much
dealt with the the D pawns have been
totally removed from the board for for
Wyatt and if black can just deal with
this one weakness then he's actually
going to be totally fine in this game
and we'll see from experience here there
are quite a number of games in this
specific line black generally just
develops this bishop and very very
quickly pushes this pawn to d5 and once
black achieves d5 historically this has
really not been not been enough to prove
an advantage for white and in addition
to that with the trade of some of these
pieces the opening of the C file this is
really going to fizzle out and do it
into a draw and so this is the type of
position that Ali Reza likes to avoid he
likes to keep more pieces on the board
give his opponent more chances to mess
up and that's how he's getting so many
practical chances and all of these games
so with that in mind let's back up to
the game here after knight c6 so
generally the line I just want looked at
white usually plays something like
Knight g3 and h3 and pushes d4 instead
ali reza plays Knight e3 and this is
really telegraphing that he's not
looking to play d4 and the reason for
that
is this night is not well placed if this
push is what he had in mind and you
might say well why is that and the
reason is you're interfering with this
Dirk's defense of the epon so you can
imagine after Bishop f8 which was played
now if you attempt something like d4
you're actually gonna run into some
pretty immediate problems where the
spawns simply going to be hanging thanks
to the pressure of the black pieces on
the east on the e-file so with this
night on III Fujiya is actually delaying
the opening up of the position kind of
passing the ball to black saying okay
I'm just gonna keep my pieces here and
do some stuff on the Queen side and I'll
let you decide when you want to open up
the center and so after Bishop f8 which
was played he actually chooses a3 which
is a little bit abnormal and after
blacks next move h6 ala Reza plays b4
and with this he's gaining some space on
the Queen side he's potentially eyeing
even some c4 breaks and he wants to open
up the position over here and
historically the way the black has dealt
with this there's a just a couple games
here when actually between Judit Polgar
and alexander only shook way back in
1997 stork Lea Black has just played a5
and with this things have kind of been
simplified a little bit on the Queen's
side white can either take here or here
historically in Judith's game we saw B
takes a 5 and after rook b1 Bishop d7
and a few more moves will go through
Knight age 2
she looked to play on the Kings side now
with this kind of nagging weakness for
black maybe this is what a Larissa had
in minds but we'll never know because
here his opponent in our Kiev decided to
break in the center with d5 and it's a
very interesting decision it's not so
bad for black really but it is kind of
daring white to ax to show his hand by
placing this knight on e3 we were
actually aiming at this d5 squared we
wanted to make this d5 break a little
bit more difficult for black to play
we saw in the standard way of playing
this Knight comes to g3 and the problem
for white is that black can usually
achieve d5 without too much difficulty
and after that occurs flex problems are
usually solved so what's the difference
here it looks as though after we take
takes takes and takes black still
doesn't really have any problems but
that can be kind of deceptive what we've
achieved by putting putting this knight
in III is rather than bringing a knight
to d5 we've drawn this queen all the way
out from d8 to d5 and firoozeh looked to
make use of the awkward placement of
this queen he does so with the strong
pawn break d4 so what does this move do
it does quite a bit it creates a lot of
tension on the c5 pawn so it's forcing
black to make a decision and in addition
it's opening up this long diagonal for
the bishop and it's also opening up this
efore square for the bishop and so you
start to see how the black pieces have
been drawn to slightly awkward squares
for example C takes d4 was played for
usual plays the very very nice move
Knight takes d4 it would be a mistake to
take back with the pun because now black
has the opportunity to keep things a
little bit more closed with the movie
for locking this pawn on a weak square
so instead Knight takes d4 is powerful
making use of this pin Bishop d7 was
played and now we see the point of Rouge
is play Bishop b4 this Queen moving from
it's awkward square has now allowed the
white pieces to gain quite a bit of
activity and already it's very very
impressive how firoozeh has managed to
draw his opponent into putting his
pieces on squares that are not quite
where it where they want to be and he's
done this by tempting his opponent into
playing the the more natural breaks even
though he has kind of aims his play
against them and so while this might not
be bad for black at all it is starting
to kind of turn in through his favor
here he's pushing the black pieces
around quite a bit
okay this Queen comes to see for now
that this pin on the rook has been
broken the white knight has to move so
it comes to f5 and we see some threats
on the Kings side starting to come come
about black decides he'd like to trade
off this this powerful Bishop so he
plays ninety eight which is a perfectly
fine move Frazier continues with Queen
f3
let me see Bishop c6 this Knight drops
back to g3 which is kind of a strange
move to my eyes I think fridge' was
aiming for some some queen uh five ideas
perhaps trying to bait black into
playing g6
but 93 still doesn't feel quite right
but White's position is totally fine we
see g6
does come on the board now we finally
see the trade of the bishops and now
Knight e4 aims at some weak dark squares
in the black camp black Reema nervous
this Bishop to g7 and this is why this
Knight g3 maneuver didn't make so much
sense to me
it really feels like g6 and Bishop g7
was something black wanted to play
anyways he puts this bishop opposite
this weak pawn on c3 and while it is
kind of blocked off by its own pawn for
the moment there's no guarantee that
it'll stay that way anyways Frazier
continues with the very natural a4
looking to gain activity and activate
his final rook and now black finally
kind of crumbles he simply plays rook c8
which is not such a good move after all
and so after a takes b5 and a takes b5
I'll ask you at home to see if you can
find the the winning tactic here for
firoozeh it's not totally winning the
game but it's very much winning material
and it's giving black quite a few
problems to solve and ok with that of
Mines here's the answer it's Queen h3
which was played in the game
and this is a very very tricky move
actually it's actually a very simple
fork and attacks the rook on c8 and the
pawn on h6
and you might be thinking well okay how
does this matter at all right that this
works defended but black plays the very
very natural King h72 defense first of
all there's Knight g5 tricks but
secondly Knight d6 would be winning the
game here and that's why this is very
very relevant now the queen is
overworked it can't both stop this
Knight from coming to d6 and defend this
rook and so white is simply winning
material and this would be disastrous
for black so what black needed to do
here was simply play Knight II 6
allowing white to capture this H pawn
and then looking for counter play with
this move f5 and this would have been a
great way for black to stay in the game
and this is what I meant by saying this
Bishop is blocked on g7 but it's
definitely not going to be permanent
this f5 pawn break could come with with
devastating effect actually allowing
black to roll the center forward and
capture on c3 unfortunately for black he
did not find this the solution to his
problems instead choosing queenie 6
which simply allows the tactic we just
looked at now after Knight d6 it's the
same story the Queen cannot capture this
knight and Queen takes h3 doesn't really
help so instead we see rook takes c3
from black and after Queen c3 Queen d6
we do have to solve this problem so
white plays York a8 and now white is
simply up in exchange for a pawn and the
rooks are getting very very active for
white in this game is pretty much dead
lost so before we look at the very end
of the game which went on for some time
but was never really out of Rouge as
control let's go back to the key move
rook c8 so this is what I'm talking
about when I say I'm mentioning fujas
experience online and it's his
experience in playing tricky chess so
what he's done is he's just placed this
night on this
efore square and it doesn't really look
threatening from efore but in fact it's
looking at some very dangerous squares
and so well on e4 it's not making any
immediate threats it's giving his
opponent the chance to allow any of
these three moves to become strong and
so of course but an archive should have
done has realized the danger that this
Knight really poses and immediately
played this move f5
this is the move that should have been
played actually a couple moments for
black this f5 move like I said forces
this night off this c4 or off this efore
square and once we continue with efore
and this Queen will have to move out of
the way
I'll let's say to d1 all of a sudden
there are some very very serious threats
on this the c3 pawn that white is going
to have to contend with it's going to be
a very active Bishop and this would be a
very very nice position for black
actually of course black can't capture
immediately due to the check but you can
imagine a simple knight f7 move
rerouting this knight now looking at
some of these open squares and defending
against any checks on the diagonal and
this position would be quite favorable
for black instead though we did see rook
c8 of course and now after takes and
Queen h3 black immediately crumbled
under the pressure
losing the exchange and will play
through the last few moves Bishop f8
Bishop e3 Queen d7 Bishop c5 ship g7 of
course in Archaea of trying to keep
pieces on the board trying to keep
chances alive but Queen f3 knight c6
takes takes Queen d5 Queen c8 and now
rook a 1 and the end is is really near
you see the coordination between the
rook and the Queen and the bishops and
it's simply too much for the black
pieces to handle black try it efore
attacking this rook very sneaky we see
rookie 195 now the e pawn falls and
after King h7 Bishop d4 Knight c4
let me see a trade of pieces always good
to trade down when you're up material
Queen d4 check King g8 h3 I like this
move in rapid chess you know just why
why why even think about hanging back
rank me just play h3 see
age five and now the Queen and the rook
work together aiming at some unfortunate
squares around this black King we see
the trade and after night a three rook
c5 it's very clear which piece is better
in this endgame in this Knight actually
quickly became trapped white simply
walks the King over to the Queen's side
and looks to collect this final piece of
Plex see Roxy to King d5 and in this
position black ended up resigning and so
this was a game that happened pretty
pretty early on in the tournament
actually for Asia but I think it's a
very typical typical game it seems as
though he didn't really do anything
super special he didn't try to
positionally you know dominate his
opponent all he does is play very
practical chess that gives him fighting
chances he allowed his opponent to make
a mistake and then he immediately found
the tactic he immediately capitalized
and ever since you know he went up
material the game was never in doubt he
you know employed perfect technique and
won the game without too much of a
struggle with that of Mines thank you
all for joining me for the very first
episode of game review my name is Caleb
Denby and I will see you next time
[Music]
you